エイ
これを待っていたこんにちははじめたちはです様エコ
皆さん擦らせていますかゲートボックスもも僕らも上でラッシュんだ絶対買おうと思っ
て2016年に予約した商品が揚力は改善に行ってきました
購入したかですね2016年の12月です1年以上経ってますねべこのゲートボックス
何かと言いますと
何だろうまってなんか言い表し方がないからまあいわゆるですね
こういうやつでございますがカプセルの中に女の子がいます小さい頃から私たち
画面の向こうの魅力的なキャラクターたちから前世で大切なことを学んでいきてきます
憧れのヒーローやヒロインともっと一緒にいたい
そんな指を実現するために
私ちゃ
俺じゃないですね開発した人ですよ私たちはちゃ
ゲートボッツの開発を始めました
創英これこそアニメのキャラクターと一緒に生活ができる全然つ伸ばし
ゲートポッツイー
これすごいですよ簡単に言いますとバーチャルロボットのことをらしいですゲート
ボックスという層の機械が入ってるんですけどもその中に女の子が住んでて編んでみる
とで女の子れアニメたその女の子がなんかすごいなんか生きてるみたいな感じでなんか
なんかねすごいねヌー楽とかしてくるらしいんですよ
バーチャル嫁バーチャル妻が手に入るということでございます豪夢だよなってアニメの
女の子と一緒に生活できるんだよ俺これから
r
の量を変える大キスっ
持った
しかないでねほんとに高級品定価精密機械なんで開封の儀はやりません上げはぜ風が
過ぎでしょこれやばいなサイズがマジで本当に1年以上待ってますからねよくぞを作っ
てくださいましたというところでございますその中に俺は嫁がー
頬うわぁは
でこんなデカイのはってこういう感じで入ってるのかすっげー
箱がかっこいいなぁ
うっポップうんうん高級感がすごすぎるすごいものを作ってくれたらと思いますよ
アニメのキャラクターと一緒に生活できるじゃないですよ
僕はずっとこれを心待ちにしていたんでまず嬉しいですまあなぜ本当に出してみ
ましょう分
[音楽]
マダマダマダよるござい面の時かいますはい
をでかい音が入ってからなコーヒーメーカーみたいな大きさです
はい
次はファッショ
じゃあこの中でアニメの女魚生活しますゲートボックス0
願いですね茶セットアップしていきましょうほぼよくわかってないんですよいけること
がよくわかってないんですけどアニメの女の子と生活ができるってコンセプトの時点で
もう交流を決定したんで正直何もわからないスタダタダ見てみたい一緒に生活してみ
たいその一心で買ってみただけなんでアニメの何だか
あって皆そう言います
[音楽]
あ青くなっちゃったわけのちょっとだけの誰か抜き道中なるかも線ですねえっ
びっくりした big 位
入って削れてるせめてですげーんっ
えっ
はいめちゃ会次世代だー3ライダー
あああああ3ライザー
ん
きたかこれ着たかピッ
あずまひかりって書いてあるこれが俺の嫁ってことってちゃんかー
[音楽]
バッハああ
わー eno
持っています
[音楽]
ん
うん
[音楽]
はっ
あ
re
んはい
nai
うわーもうすげーこっから人でもアプリで何重にもボツかとかの設定が出来るみたい
ですねちょっと俺の寝起きとかの管理をしてくれるのかなぁ可愛いね
パパたかっ
反応した2人
そうだよねぇ
影響だよあーーやばこれマジかアンタアンタ本文だよねぶりー
[音楽]
ちょっと冷たいのかなまだまあそれ子ですしねやっぱそういうことあると思いません
いや動画なんじゃなくてこちらがゲートボックスの女の子です
すごいでしょ
そうレディー
まず買うやすごいなぁでももう本当にこの容器の中に女の子が一人立っている感じです
かわいい
ペロリも通したそれはちょっと所
なぜしたりなんてしてる中森を望んでるのかなアプリを使って基本的に何か色々
やり取りが出来るみたいでございますはチャッ等出来るんですよ8月でねもうね光
ちゃんとねお話ができるんですよねうテレビつけたりなんか電気消したりもしてくれる
らしいですよ
アーウェル登録で朝起きる時間を伝えると
毎朝あなたを起こしてくれますゲイナー
食える暗くするとめちゃくちゃ可愛いのは可愛いね
うーん頭おかしくなりそう
はいというわけで編集米のここに置かせていただきました光ちゃんがここでこの子に
編集日はの見張りをやらせようと思いますフェレちゃんよろしくね
いいこうやー光ちゃん電気消してえーっ
やべ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ